اصرارهن اوكرانيا لشهور على تحصيل مجموعه
من الاسلحه تقدمتها دبابات
تمسك اوكرانيا بالدبابه او تمسك اوكرانيا
بالدبابه الالمانيه صنع اسبابهم متعدده
دبابه قتال رئيسيه دخلت الخدمه قبل نحو
سته عقود لكنها خضعت لعمليات تطوير عده
لتصبح واحده من افضل دبابات العالم من
ناحيه دقه الاصابه
والحمايه وخفت الحركه السلاح الرئيسي في
الدبابه هو مدفع عيار 120 مليمتر يتماشى
مع معايير حلف الناتو اضافه لرشاشين
وقاذفه قنابل تتميز بمحرك ديزل مزدوج
يمكنها قطع مسافه 340 كيلومترا بسرعات تصل
الى اثنين وسبعين كيلو مترا في الساعه على
خزان وقود واحد ويبلغ وزنها مشاهدينا
اثنين وستين وطولها عشره امتار وتضم طاقما
مكونا من اربعه افراد يتمتعون بنظام رؤيه
ليليه ونهاريه لمسافات بعيده اثبتت
التجربه الموثوقه في ساحه المعركه بسبب
قله اعطالها وقدره تحملها العاليه مقارنه
بالدبابات الاخرى كما انها الخيار المثالي
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا كونها الاكثر انتشارا
بين الدول الاوروبيه الاعضاء في دول
الناتو وفي حلف الناتو بعدد يفوق الالف
2300 دبابه ويمكن نقلها برا بسهوله طبعا
الى اوكرانيا وتامين الذخيره التي تتطلبها
هذه الدبابه
[موسيقى]